like hospital-acquired infections.
I believe this has got to be, in part,
a building ecology problem.
All right, I'm going to tell you one more story about this building.
I am collaborating with Charlie Brown.
He's an architect,
and Charlie is deeply concerned about global climate change.
He's dedicated his life to sustainable design.
When he met me and realized that it was possible for him
to study in a quantitative way
how his design choices impacted
the ecology and biology of this building,
he got really excited, because it added a new dimension to what he did.
He went from thinking just about energy
to also starting to think about human health.
He helped design some of the air handling systems
in this building and the way it was ventilated.
So what I'm first going to show you is
air that we sampled outside of the building.
What you're looking at is a signature of bacterial communities
in the outdoor air, and how they vary over time.
Next I'm going to show you what happened
when we experimentally manipulated classrooms.
We blocked them off at night
so that they got no ventilation.
A lot of buildings are operated this way,
probably where you work,
and companies do this to save money on their energy bill.
What we found is that these rooms remained relatively stagnant
until Saturday, when we opened the vents up again.
When you walked into those rooms,
they smelled really bad,
and our data suggests that it had something to do with
leaving behind the airborne bacterial soup
from people the day before.
Contrast this to rooms
that were designed using a sustainable passive design strategy
where air came in from the outside through louvers.
In these rooms, the air tracked the outdoor air relatively well,
and when Charlie saw this, he got really excited.
He felt like he had made a good choice
with the design process
because it was both energy efficient
and it washed away the building's resident microbial landscape.
The examples that I just gave you are about architecture,
but they're relevant to the design of anything.
Imagine designing with the kinds of microbes that we want
in a plane
or on a phone.
There's a new microbe, I just discovered it.
It's called BLIS, and it's been shown
to both ward off pathogens
and give you good breath.
Wouldn't it be awesome if we all had BLIS on our phones?
A conscious approach to design,
I'm calling it bioinformed design,
and I think it's possible.
Thank you.
(Applause)